hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grind la
la hello and welcome to the new world
it's bad because i know liam's gonna use
it against me aren't you you horrible
person
i'll admit before wing turned up i was
starting to think that perhaps wing was
hisoka without makeup maybe i
grand lime waifu and more wing than
chicken it's like this is the gong gone
fruit and hisoka is just waiting for it
to ripen so he can enjoy the delectable
juices and
no please child you do not have the
appropriate training
nor do you have appropriate ppe do not
i repeat do not go out into the ring to
fight against a man who is better with
small toys than you
that's not great hisoka is upside down
as a magician in many ways which makes
sense because if you look at his hair
maybe that's how he sleeps
like a bat except we aren't shocked are
we because we know that gone isn't human
as much as we know that kilauea is in
fact some kind of
rat life form i'm unsure but there's no
harm in charmingly
trying to farm alarm in a man of full of
smart the exits are here here and here
i'm over here here and now i'm here whoa
i'm everywhere gosh hisoka's a weirdo
isn't he
oh i wonder if she's the lay audio
equivalent on their team
you're training with by all accounts at
this point a foul who is teaching you to
protect yourself little sushi is
literally the purest most adorable part
of this series so far
and while i understand that that is a
good reason to put a target on him
how very dare you didn't mind showing
his tush to point out he is the main
event
i really should have expected the
schwing of his schlong and a spoiler
this time it's okay my friends it's okay
if i use spoilers because you won't
remember any of this happened
you will forget whatever happens in this
we've had a lot of law handed to us over
the last few episodes and they've held
varying degrees of interest to me can we
just enjoy for a moment that gone has a
boom
box
speaking of walking into danger it's one
thing for his dad to be perched on top
of a mini beast near a volcano another
to be perched on top of a mini beast on
top of a dragon near a volcano so he's
not a cow anymore he's a pig
i know you i know where you are i know i
don't know where you are i know who you
are
either way he has a pretty new skirt for
the new arc and i can't wait to see him
fight but then who could write haiku and
be
evil myself excluded that is not that
i'm evil
this may be a lie strange rat person
music heart melody reader she not he
does that mean he's trying to control
the rage or that he's so angry that it's
bursting through despite his attempts to
hold it together
but instead we cut away to the farm
where piggy's helping us tie up loose
ends with the help of his perfectly
spotlit
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] who knows corapica
also wants to kill the phantom troop
which is really convenient because
they've decided to steal
check note everything how is this
auction going to go
okay i have 31 billion 31 31 32 32 32
billion 37 37 43 43 do i hear
okay i'm sorry there is nothing to sell
but the eyes of that curta
over there internet cafes was that ever
a thing did
i miss that it also turns out kilo was
awful at stock market we got a huge
number of names that i feel like i'm
supposed to remember and i'm good at
names
[Music]
phantom troop healing woman phantom
troopy guy the creepy big-eyed one
vacuum girl gunfinger man
weird sideburn guy and that guy from my
hero academia
[Music]
there was no schwing but i expect one in
future i
i try to sound clever
what is that i can do that too
he's only learned 10. maybe i am farm
boy indeed it does feel as though i was
10 the last time i was outside so to be
directly called out in this economy
seems unfair
actually it highlights something really
important well two things
maybe three things i appreciate the
names for these powers by the way the
ambidextrous double machine gun is
indeed fearsome and cute all at once but
there are a lot of double crosses double
crossing more double crosses which is
very
odd and i don't know what's going on but
at least i know that i don't know what's
going on
you're crazy the restraining middle
finger is the most
metal thing i've ever heard oh well he's
dead now too
wait he's dead too now he's hmm and
korapika is apparently at luna park
which is a really boring fairground in
sydney with a hisoka-like face as the
logo i found it interesting that their
focus is on stealing
killing and philanthropy do they have a
website what's their philosophy do they
have like an about us page episode 46
46 yes episode 46 oh gone
killa and leorio how do you get anything
done without kurapika
he wants to swing in the direction of
the leader of the phantom troop kurapika
seems to be playing both the long game
and oddly
the short game why is the mummy so
important to you what is it about a
mummy that's causing her such distress
and what's going to happen when she
acquires a mummy
is it her mummy maybe it's her mummy oh
what a strange kid
i want to get to the next episode so
let's do exactly that candy break good
candy also you had
leech eggs in your pea the number of
eggs that came out and with their size
how big must this genitals actually be
and karapika's stripping style swank
emperor time
he took out his contacts so we got to
see his eyes blazing then we found out
that he was a specialist and oh boy it
was all over
i now know a lot more about appraising
artifacts than i ever needed or wanted
to
as one of my notes states no gio for
leorio
does he want me to draw those eyebrows
on him does he want me to do it while
he's sleeping
i guess i'll have to find out and report
back i am the knower of arts and riches
now give me the art that i wanted in the
first place but fought to claim for
these children
look i'll even cut it open and this
entire exchange was absurd
you will do this and grow because you
can and because i said so and i am gone
the magnificent he seems to be
collecting men who show more interest in
him than they should
gon seems to be very intent on people
learning to live to their potential and
while that shouldn't surprise me there's
a
bug on my wall it's time for us to take
a look at episode the next
it's been a big week i don't know where
we are i don't think i don't see you
there leorio failing to be useful while
egging on the little ones
you go and hide yeah sure it's such an
interesting conundrum
to can conundrum who says that now
replace all of them with hisoka
ah that's better y'all i get names
right in this episode i do they care
about each other too and nothing made
that more clear than nobunaga no
i guess episode i do i do
i hate names i hate names i hate names
hey do you want to join the troupe
oh wait hang on he never speaks out loud
hey do you want to join the truth
wait it's even lower than that hey do
you want to join the troop
beyond literally placing us between the
legs of breasty mcgee which seems
unnecessary to be in the dark is to end
up in the dark pits of illumi's nen
or ren or in i'm so confused by these
i'm i'm sorry that each member of the
troop relates to a month in some way
that's something i'm gonna have to
consider and i'm really glad that i have
things to consider don't think i didn't
notice papa's aldix there
it's just that so many other things
happened my brain skimmed the importance
of it
is it the same as um melody is it the
same as melody like like is that
is that a thing is that what we're
saying like oh hello
and welcome to the new world review i'm
grand line waifu and today we're going
to spend a lot of time talking about a
family i gloss over every time they turn
up there will be spoilers
there will be dislike there will be like
silva and xeno
zeno zeno silva zeno zeno i
look names i just they're all a pack of
really aren't they maybe i've been
working too hard and need to take a leaf
out of their very lazy self-serving
self-aggrandizing book
god i hate them they're not even they're
not even poor dead bean
i didn't hate bean he had a cute name
and no ability to think for himself
rip sean bean again and who the hell is
cortopi
and where the hell is piggy that second
point might be more because they're an
important part of the ecosystem of evil
evil system if you will as long as it
doesn't sustain as long as we don't stay
in this place of like it's great either
the maid is going to die or dogman who
has the most adorable puppies
just saying yay puppies the fact that
kurapika's chains are a way to force
zetsu would be really important if i
could remember what
all these things did okay let's see um
zetsu is the way to avoid being detected
detective zetsu you don't deserve a
nuvogen mark
ii you didn't take care of the first one
we can't trust you
pakunoda also went on a journey as did
them today's
meanwhile leorio's missing out on
everything because he's stuck in traffic
yes this here this guy here this dude
my dude is the voice of reason sometimes
i love my notes
let me read some for you strong boobs
misha
or whatever her name is has incredible
abs and i want them
abs that can trap a hand gimme i want
that power i said
steaming good thoughts like steamed buns
but thoughts i steam
you steam we all steam for hisoka's
steamed schwing
i want more delicious reveals from
crollow specifically huh they're not
healthy or normal people and they have
magical powers i guess so that's another
thing kilwa is also not a buffoon
meanwhile gone signature power becoming
power fists
is also very much in keeping with his
own goku-like hair and demeanor which
came first the goku or the gone
i'm gonna say that probably the gone
actually we're gonna do some item
collecting we're gonna do some choosing
of people and characters we've got to
collect some hunter cards and maybe
we'll see
and maybe we'll see jing kurapika cute
little
hallucinating kurapika what licking and
eating and chowing their chinese so cute
so that's it from me
i'm getting angry because i'm hungry i'm
hangry if you enjoyed this episode
click that thing that thing or that
thing you better click this thing
i'm sure there are a lot of things on
screen that you can click it's fun
clicking things so click things now
i'm hungry liam please feed me